so we're going to start this session
with a bang we have our church you might
speaking on fast testing of graph
properties our tour is at the University
of Warwick and I'm not going to give you
a whole history because it's long and
brilliant but um so I'll just leave it
at that thank you very much so a I'm
really from the university of warwick
and i want to tell you something about a
can you hear me well good i want to tell
you something about fast algorithms for
testing graph properties so what we want
to do is want to analyze process big
graphs so in this talk big data means
big graph and what want to do it want to
study basic properties of big drops and
analyze them the structure so you know
this so normally when we are talking
about graph algorithms we think okay the
graph consists of 50 or 5000 nodes here
focuses want to study big drops we don't
specify what doesn't mean big this is an
example of graph which could be
considered weak and for such graphs as
you may have heard yesterday stock pile
or need a were very often interested in
analyzing the properties but want to do
it very fast by that we mean in
sublinear time which is the time faster
than the time needed to read the entire
input and in this talk would like to
study basic graph properties in the
context of a framework of property
tastic okay so we have this big round
and what our kind of properties want to
study so here are some examples we want
to check if the graph has some big
clique or has some simple structure like
a triangle or is the graph planar is a
good expander what are the basic
properties that the graph have a what we
know is that because we want to do it in
time sublinear which means we
cannot process the entire graph advanced
they would have to make some sacrifices
and in particular I want to do
approximation want to study some
approximate conditions properties of the
graph and the probability testing has
been a design to formalize this
framework in particular in property
testing what we want to do is would like
to take us and input a graph and say
except the graph if the graph satisfy
some property for example is planar or
reject the graph it is far from
satisfying the property so we don't want
to just say plane and on plane I want to
say ok planar Oh far from being planar
and yesterday wrong it'll be felt gave
some a general exposition what does it
mean in the context of property testing
to study these properties and what is
the reasoning what is the motivation so
he is kind of more precise framework so
we want to take as an input a graph as
an input the property and if the graph
satisfied property want to say ok want
to pass it if the input is epsilon far
from satisfying the property then want
to say that want to reject it and in
addition to that we allow some error so
with probabilities say one third to one
quarter we are allowed to air ok so in
particular if the graph is need satisfy
the proper tour is not far away we to
some extent don't care what is the
answer now here few formal issues so
what does it mean notion of this epsilon
far if we want to measure the distance
from graph satisfying a property and he
was saying a graph is epsilon far from
satisfying appropriate if a change of
epsilon fraction of the input is
required to transform the graph into one
that satisfy the property okay and here
we usually will assume epsilon is a
small constant like for example 18.9
point one
so epsilon is usually you should think
it's a concept but it's small constant a
then the next thing is in this talk we
improperly testing we want to
distinguish between algorithms which
have two side of error so this albert is
two-sided error algorithm and one side
there are algorithms one sided never
airs in this case so if the graph has
property will always want to satisfy it
will always want to return true a one of
useful properties of this is that
one-sided error error algorithms they
often if the graph is epsilon far from
satisfying the property the orphan can
return is certificate that the graph is
far ok so this is the mobile and now so
we have the model we have to formalize
what doesn't mean that the graph is
epsilon far from satisfying the property
or in other words epsilon fraction of it
its representations needed to obtain
graph satisfying the property in the
most natural model and actually the
first motor that people study is the
model of adjacency matrix so the input
is defined by zero our matrix and by n
corresponding to n a to graph with n
vertices in this case the epsilon far
means we have to modify an epsilon
fraction of entries in this graph to
obtain a graph satisfying given property
in other words oh sorry and he will
assume that this graph is given us an
Oracle so in every step we can ask a
question ok eh I saw each vertex I
connected to vertex J a in this model if
you look at the definition epsilon
fraction of the entire matrix means were
allowed to modify epsilon n square edges
in the ground ok so this is the model
and here's kind of once again repetition
what we want to start this want to study
the complexity of tester which is the
number of entries the algorithm
adjacency matrix the algorithm
okay so let's just start with very basic
problem actually two basic problems so
we are given some huge round and want to
see the graph the property that's a
graph site it has a triangle or does
graph is strongly free so the first
thing does the graph has a triangle it
is a very simple property testing
Calgary why this is the case because
we're allowed to modify epsilon n square
edges we can make every graph to pass a
triangle we just have to add three edges
so in this case the question should be
always yet however if we want to see the
graph is triangle free this is
completely different game and actually
some deep coming at orix has been used
to show that we can also taste this
property very quickly so we can taste it
in time f of epsilon where epsilon we
said is a constant so in this case this
means in a constant time we can just in
constant time test it brap is a triangle
free or epsilon far from triangle free
excuse me we'll come to this later and
that's an excellent point so then the
next thing is one of first observation
that people made when others well
analyzing this type of algorithms they
observe that all our items can be of the
following very simple form you just
randomly sample some set of vertices
then you look at the graph induced by
these vertices and if the graph satisfy
a property you accept it if the graph
doesn't satisfy the property you
rejected and all testing algorithms can
be described in this form and this can
be done with just quadratic loss of the
speed so if you get a nugget of this
form and you know it's time is T and you
know you cannot have faster algorithms
this form then there is no other testing
algorithms which be faster than root of
T yes
quite complexity so number of cells was
too
yes so we are only the entire complex it
is just the number of entries in the
matrix would be interesting and by the
way here is also a lot of thing for
example this property doesn't have to be
the same as the original property but
its technical ish okay hey now they are
very fast algorithms a very fast
property testing and asks you have seen
all of them but very simple so for
example for testing by party place we
can ensure that all our items can be of
this very simple form sample set of
vertices check if the Indians graph is
bipartite if it is accepted if it's not
rejected what is the only thing that
won't understand here is what is the
size of the sample set of vertices yeah
and here so there were some papers first
someone show that one can do it in time
with the sample size of size portfolio
of 1 over epsilon and then it was
improved to OnStar of 1 over epsilon
where for information be using this
notation star to hide logarithmic terms
so this is 1 over epsilon times poly log
of 1 over epsilon and once we have this
size of you the complexity is always
square of that because he was just
looking at number of vertices and if
want to look at the graph induced by
these vertices the complexity will be
your square ok so for many years people
trying to study all kinds of properties
and then came a very general result our
Shapira show that all hereditary
properties can be tested in concept i'm
assuming epsilon is a constant and this
is even with one sided arrow what are
hereditary property these are all
properties which hold even if you remove
vertices so being bipartite k colorable
etc the main idea he was this very
simple lemma which is essentially saying
that if graph is epsilon far from
satisfying some hereditary property then
we fight with constant probability
ninety-nine percent a a random sub graph
of size which depends only on epsilon a
will not satisfy property p so somehow
we have this big graph for example
triangle freeness is hereditary property
so we have the bounded if we just
randomly sample some constant number of
entries or vertices in the graph and
look at the graph induced by it will
find a triangle if the graph original
graph was epsilon far from tonga
treatments and this was obtained by the
use of a similar dilemma and actually
for example it can be extended to
hypergraphs so the same result is a hold
for high programs and then this this
gives us essentially precise
characterization of all a property's
testable in constant time with one sided
arrow because these are only hereditary
properties to some extent a so this
gives us full characterization now one
can actually extend this to also a
double sided two sided arrow and then
there is some slightly more complicated
description but essentially graph
properties testable across some time if
only if testing can be reduced to
something on Sandra Dee partitions ok so
this is what people are doing for many
years and this final result was amazing
now so we have very simple algorithms we
understand the small model very well
because we have almost complete
characterization what can be tested
quickly the main problem is really the
dependency on epsilon and the running
time of the running time generated by
this adam shapiro result was of this
form so this is 222 and you just do it
many many times to 1 over epsilon so the
precise characterization is that if we
define power of C like that so just do
two to two and you will repeat this C
times a
in the running time obtained by this
general machinery both power of tower of
power of 1 over epsilon a so once i
computed for absolutely call to half
you'd have to ride 65 thousand times 2
to the power to obtain around so what
does mean it is not really very
practical bound
stay there are some so let let's be
positive there are some properties with
when we can do much better for example
by partners we can do it in time 1 over
epsilon square but for example in this
problem of checking if graph is trying
to free the best currently known bound
is power of 1 over epsilon and for many
years Archer people conjecture that this
is the flower bound now actually some
people are people are not sure this
related to so-called triangle removal
lamer witches people as have been
studied for many years and we said there
was some progress so there is actually
chance that one can be this bountiful
now just if you want to check it bloody
struggle free you have this horrendous
time ok a so we do have some problems in
this model the first I mean the biggest
problem is perhaps that the dependency
on epsilon is very quite big and the
second problem is that we are here
requiring the distance from the property
to be epsilon n square so if you have
some kind of typical big graph which is
usually sparse the distance epsilon
square is really too big so you can try
to remove you can try to reduce the
distance you can try to take eps not not
necessary to be a constant say go to one
over N or something like that but then
this dependency on epsilon would kill us
so on one hand would have a beautiful
characterization of this model on the
other hand there are some problems why
it is difficult for you to do anything
ok so once we we have seen this model
and this was the main model in property
testing for 15 years perhaps let's just
think what to do with other models so
the next most natural model is adjacency
list or in other words so you are given
a graph he'll have set of vertices each
vertex know its neighbors and we have a
query which is so you can pick a vertex
and say
what is the eighth labor of the vertex
in this case the distance is define us
okay we can modify epsilon x number of
edges edges in this compare to obtain
graph which is epsilon far so this is
suitable for sparse graph is suitable
for any grams the main model that people
been studying though was the model of
bounded graphs so graphs with max you'd
agree d what is a constant the reason is
that then you can really think that you
know this adjacency list is I can just
in constant time check everything with
all my neighbors so this is kind of the
most natural model it's still not the
most general but it's to some extent the
most natural model a and then quite
often with us instead of using this
bound for epsilon times e we are just
saying you are allowed to modify epsilon
the energies okay so in this model a max
of the greedy first information is we
don't have such strong links to
communities he were using slightly
different set of tools and main of main
tools are random sampling clock on
search and random walks and I'll try to
give you some examples of the use of
these tools here ok so first one to
start perhaps the most basic question of
testing connectivity so we are given a
graph want to see if it's connected or
not or its epsilon far from being
connected a so we have to understand
what does mean that guap is epsilon far
from being connected and this it's easy
to see it means that the graph there's
lots of connective components a this
percent it's not enough to really
understand efficient algorithm but if
you have lots of connected components we
can actually see that many of them will
be small so we have a good number of
small connected components so we have at
least epsilon times DN half connected
components of size of that song
and once we have it what we are doing we
randomly sample vertices we check if
this vertex is in a small connected
component and if it is we know this
graph exceptional apart from being
connected ok so here's an algorithm this
sample some subvert of vertices we then
run BFFs or any algorithm attacking is
this graph a small connected component
or not so if you run DFS and you see
that the collection opponent is being
you just stop but if you have a graph
which is absolutely far from being a
connected you know you have lots of
small connect components so you know
that one of these randomly chosen
vertices will be in such connected
component and then you just detect it
quickly so if this you can come up with
a testing connectivity algorithm in this
run so this is a very basic I'll go to
actually showing us that even some
global properties can be tested in this
model very quickly hey then the next
thing is testing H Venus so before we
have seen that you know testing triangle
Flynn is a complicated task we can do it
in constant time by the time is enormous
here the problem is much easier so it
graph is epsilon far from triangle free
we can easily show it has lots of
disjoint triangles and so randomly
random sampling so you just randomly
sampling vertices and then you just see
is this vertex in a triangular node and
again because these are constant so
these are constant degree graphs you can
easily to it in constant time so with
this would like to also do the same
thing as we did before understand which
properties will have causal time
algorithms and then we move to the next
property which seems to be very basic by
parted nice and then things are
complicated so for testing by partners
there was a very nice algorithmic in
time essentially root of n buy gold rush
and wrong and don't do it was as follows
so this handbook was random is sampling
some set of vertices and then for each
vertex on who is doing the
following1 root of n random walks of
logarithmic length okay so essentially
run so many random walks / I'll root of
N and each random walk is of length no
game and if one of these random walks
will find that we have an auto laying
cycle which is which is approved that
the graph is not bipartite then we just
return say no if all of this random
walks will find that all the cycles
found our of even lengths that will
return yes and the main idea here is
that if work is really far away from
bipartite that we'll be able to find
lots of short cycles of on length and
this Cypress we did we can detect you
think random walks and random something
the proof is quite complicated there are
kind of two different cases one if if
the graph is an excellent expander and
then things are easy and another is if
we graph is not expanded and then one
has to do something so this was one
thing which was okay so we have our guys
running it run time root of n can we do
better and gold rush and Ron show that
we can not redo it better so there is a
lower bound of root of n which is
essentially focusing everything on
distinguishing between two types of
instances so in both instances we first
start with commit on a cycle and then in
one we take a random matching and this
random matching will have lots of
outlying cycles and then random matching
but we bound on leg cycles which will
not generate or length cycles and one
can prove that one needs root of n time
to distinguish between these three
instances
okay so the bad news is we don't have
constant time algorithms even from kind
of basic properties and then the
extension of bipartite nice to color
color ability III color ability and he
was even worse bound a suburb dunno for
beta Trevisan show that essentially to
test this property one has to pass an
entire graph so the running time is
essentially linear so this shows a big
discrepancy between this type of this
model and the previous model what we can
do lots of thinking constant time even
though concert was huge here we can we
need to spend more time then I want to
tell you something about testing some
basic properties a first let's just
think about a sickly city so we want to
check if a graph is a forest or not and
here again I want to show that there is
a big difference between one sided arrow
and two sided arrow and so to sign the
terror is much easier so if you want to
pass it Braff is a forest the following
algorithm will do it easily so we first
look at the graph we estimate the number
of edges then you look at the graph will
estimate the number of connected
component and there is a well-known
formula which put them together in the
case of forest so it is a forest the
formulas hold otherwise we just reject
the ground and if one implemented
properly one can get the running time of
this side of this song what about one
sided arrow and then the story is
similar to buy partners we cannot do it
much better so the first thing is a
there is a lower bound by gold rush and
on the same as Ferb attractiveness which
is root of N and there is also an upper
bound where we can show that we can
solve it in time root of n a and I will
show you the the construction because I
think it's one of cute constructions
here I'm I so I don't we have many
probes this is perhaps the only
reconstruction
so we want to test by people on two
tests what the graph is a forest or not
so whether we have cycles or not will
reduce it to the problem by party place
how will do it so we take it round and
now on each edge with primary half we'll
put another vertex so okay so each so we
just choose so for every edge we just we
probably have we just put a new vertex
in the middle and now the claim is if
the original graph had cycles okay this
graph will have lots of cycles of length
and width this will be able to detect it
using my party dress test a so we have
the first observation if the
oceanographic cycle-free the doc time
graph is obtained graph is also
cycle-free so of course it won't be it
will be by pattern otherwise the claim
is it will have a lot it will be epsilon
far from bipartite and with this we can
use the tester of gold rush' wrong okay
so this is what we'll do a the next
thing is out sorry the next thing is
they we're studying the extension of
this so here we wanted to find if you
have a cycle what about having Satan
being sake ck mine or free which means
that we don't have any cycle of length
at most a having no sank cycle of length
at least K and we can extend our bound
and also show that in this case we can
also get rid of an runtime and
furthermore we can actually make it
algorithmic so this is because we have
one sided arrow problem so you can show
that it broke exceptional far from sake
I seek a minor free then we can find a
long cycle in this ground
okay and then we can also show that
actually this balance of root of K again
are tied so we can show that for any
fixed graph age that contains a simple
cycle a testing mine or H freeness
requires at least root of n time we can
actually extend it further we can also
show some complimentary result so that
if you take any tree then testing mine
or T freeness can be done in constant
time and what what does it mean really
we can come up with the following
general result that if we were to tell
test if a graph is H meinl free then we
can test it in concert time if I leave
age doesn't have cycle and if H has a
cycle we need at least root of n time
okay so what did what did I try to tell
you I wanted to show you that some very
basic properties bye-bye partners eh
freeness originally in the first model
we could have test them in console time
here we need root of n time and
algorithms are more sophisticated
analysis perhaps more complicated and
then let's just think about the next
possible big problem we have a big R a
friend who want to understand is this
graph planar and there was a beautiful
result by benjamini SRAM Shapira to show
that with two sided arrow we can test
this property in constant time so you
know by parted pneus we cannot test but
planarity we can test which is kind of
surprising now there is even something
more surprising eh so the ass and browse
and you can think about simply expand
their regular expand their a where if
you take yes bout the degree
yes so it is easy to see the dark bars
which are epsilon far from being planar
and if you will get any constant size
connected subgraph they are planar a
good example here our exam expanders
let's say three regular expanders we
know that they will have gas logarithmic
so somehow these graphs are as far from
expanded from planar as possible but if
you look at any constant size sub graph
they are planar so to some extent this
result is quite surprising and the main
idea really what they were doing is that
even though you know if you look at any
constant size bra it will be planar you
look at the shape of this constant size
crops and you can see that it broke
exceptional far from planar you have
very different structure this was so
this led to an algorithm with such a
running time so this was still not good
but this was later improved to time
which was 22 poly of 1 over epsilon by
Hasidim at all and they get simple
analysis simpler algorithm which was
really using the fact that if graph
exceptional far from planar that it
either has lots of constant size
non-planar sub graphs or it has lots of
small sub graphs we found good separator
which look which look like expanded and
then recently this was improved even
further and the currently based bound
here is 2200 block Square 1 of 1 over
epsilon so this is not polynomial of in
1 over epsilon but just slightly super
polynomial okay so this is two sided
arrow what about one sided arrow and
hear the stories easy it is easy to see
that we cannot do anything in time
better than root of n so as before here
we have
some time for one side for two sided
arrow root of n time at best for a one
sided arrow a now this is not only for
planar graphs so one can easily extend
it to every minor closed property so
this really goes beyond just planar
graphs then we have seen that if a graph
is good XP good if a graph is planar has
good separators then we can quickly
efficiently test properties of this
ground what about the brabus doesn't
have good separators is an expander so
in expanders the intuition was the
tastic properties might be hard and this
was this led to the start of this
problem can we distinguish if in graph
which are good expanders and grab such a
poor expanders and he was a paper where
so it was known that you need that we
need at least root of in time and he
will show that actually we can test this
property in root of n time hey now here
is the algorithm and down to the pyp is
very nice so one randomly sample
vertices and then from each vertex from
each sample vertex one run root of n
random walks of logarithmic that length
now what we are doing then we are
looking only at the end nodes of this
random walks and two are counting having
of this end nodes repeat and now why do
we do it so it is well known that if
input graph is an expander and we run
random walk that will end up at a random
note so in the first case if a graph is
good expander we can easily estimate how
many collisions will have because this
would be just random notes so the key
part here is to say if graph is epsilon
far from expander then we'll have many
more collisions at one can formalize
in the previous result I was just
assuming the input graph is arbitrary
right now I would like to show you very
briefly that we can also start the
properties of special classes of graphs
for example of planar graphs the good
thing is in planar graphs life is much
easier as we should expect so the first
thing is so we have seen that in
arbitrary grabs testing by particles
required root of n time in planar graphs
we can do it in constant time and the
following very simpler that is doing it
randomly sample vertices then look at
the neighborhood of constant size and if
you see it if everything is by parted
bipartite in the text pan in that
neighborhood you accept the ground if at
least once you found an opening cycle
you check the ground and one can come up
with a complexity of this sword so this
simple graph kind of doing random
sampling and then doing some like bffs
will do the job and in fact one can show
that the same idea can be extended not
just by partners but to all hereditary
properties we can show that testing any
hereditary property can be done in the
same way in constant time you randomly
sample some constant number of vertices
then you do you look at the ball of
constant size if they grab satisfy the
property except if the graph doesn't
satisfy in at least one of the copies
you're just rejected and okay so
then actually this can be expanded
beyond planar graphs so the only
property that is really essential here
is that the graphs have good separate
good separators so we can say that the
same algorithms will work for non
expanding families of grass and this was
formalized by the notion of high-profile
wraps which are exactly graphs which
have good separator properties and this
was kind of finalized in a beautiful
result by newman and solar to show the
testing any property in high profile at
grams a can be done in constant time
this algorithm is non-uniform so what
does mean general graphs we may be very
very slow which means root of n time in
planar graphs or graphs with good
separation we can do things in constant
time and the length the final somehow
big topic I'll back you tell you is how
to deal with graphs which are not bound
the degree that
I would have to think please no I would
have to I still would like to finish it
come out back Hey so the next thing is
want to study graphs which not
necessarily have bound a degree and in
this model the problem is completely
different so here for example if you
want to pass planarity it doesn't matter
one sided two sided arrow we need root
of in time and approve any counter
example is as follows one example is
taking an empty graph Novartis's okay
then of course you always say yes and on
the other hand take a graph which where
you have a clique of size root of n and
then the remaining vertices of degree
zero and outward in the model i just
described to you we require through the
fun time to distinguish between these
two cases so what can we say about this
model without bound for the maximum
degree a so here we have so many edges
that we have to modify and it will
consider the model where we have either
one of these two properties so either we
can ask for the eyes neighbor or we can
ask for the maximum degree because
otherwise would be bounded by the
maximum degree which could be huge or we
can also consider model with random
neighbor of any vertex so in any step we
can say give me a random neighbor of the
verdicts and the main the main
difference between this model in the
previous model is that here we can not
redo graph exploration quickly running
BFS you can have one vertex with degree
n so just running BFS would be extremely
expensive anything so you have to deal
with other type of properties and here
we have one result which to some extent
perhaps the only non [ __ ] result which
is testing in planar graphs well we have
shown that testing by partners in planar
graphs can be done in constant time and
the algorithm is quite simple a we run
many random walks and all of them are
constant size and we train if the graph
is not by
apartheid then one of the random walks
will spot this one so furthermore we can
extend this beyond planar graphs we can
deal with all graphs of excluded minor
forbidden minor air and we have also
some partial result about expert
extension beyond by parting lines okay
so what I wanted to present you today is
that once we have big wraps and all what
we want to do is we have to deal with
something algorithms then on one hand I
mean we have to study these problems
because this is what what we have to do
nowadays for some problems we can come
up with very quick algorithms for some
others for to pass some other properties
we have some natural our bounds a still
understanding of testing properties in
graphs especially graphs would bound the
degree model adjacency list or even more
arbitrary grams in adjacent is our
knowledge is very punchy so here's kind
of short summary of the results that we
have here in adjacency matrix model we
have complete characterization still
down gotham's are not as practical as
they should be in adjacency list model
will help some basic characterizations
but lots of questions are still open and
we we also know that for graph without
expanding properties lots of properties
can be tested very quickly a but grass
with no bound for the degree very little
is known and we still need to understand
this model and I still in my opinion
this is the most natural model we should
think of so what to do in a graph well
we don't have any bound for the degree
you may have some vertices with huge
degree somewhat very low degree we can
access adjacency lists which is the most
natural presentation what can we test
quickly and there are still some other
models which are well study but which i
haven't mentioned here is what to do
with directed graphs what to do with
graphs where instead of adjacency list
we have other access to the input for
example we can take random edge and also
what can we say about graphs went way
when the edges have some ways but there
is still lots of open problems research
problems here and I believe that if we
want to understand big data be grabs we
must think about problems how to
understand how to tackle the properties
of graphs in big crops thank
you